and this is ashwin our musical and
enhancing technology no chances of India
and their demos with accelerating the
atmosphere of intellectual discourse is
setting snow on the mountains and I ask
myself what is it that I'm taking away
from our this time you are and the only
answer that I get is that a lot of
history complete around the world one
message I how does out loud with her
dreams that this is any world we are
going to scripting and the new world
demands accountability of power power of
capitals our politics and power of the
particular solution we have this is a
world where power has been dispersed as
a fragmented power power of capitalist
pregnant is a part of ideas has
fragmented itself and all of us have to
discover for ourselves the truth of this
reality and therefore governments all
over the world will now have to be
transparent accountable to the people in
whose name the exercise power likewise
for global capital again happy and there
were no bility of the peoples of the
world disoriented do which governments
and capital you have to respond to if
they have to be acceptable to the
communities at large the second point
that I made here in Davos in other
concessions is that science and
technology have to be at the core of the
kind of society that we own makin a 21st
century and for science become relevant
the people acknowledge it needs to be
informed by the inside of the social
scientists and will form by the custom
of community one last point that I
thought is important for me to make it
is this to win the trust of the people
will believe respond with challenge
all those who own an exercise at Elton
has any I I targeted by itself above the
sweet generous to have the conditioner
by the way the legal in whose name power
is exercised and anthologies exercise do
it